So how many people would like to find
their blind spot, raise your hand.
You can't, it's blind, no.
We're going to do that.
So it's actually really, really easy.
Couple of ways we can do this.
So, on my screen right now, I have
a picture of a, a plus and a, and a dot.
Your blind spot is always on
the outside of your visual field.
So what I'm going to do is, I'm going to
look for the blind spot in my left eye.
So it's going to be outside.
So what I'm going to do is,
I'm going to, whoa!
It happened right now.
So right now I'm looking at
that dot on the right, and
to the left of it is a cross.
And if I move here, there's the cross.
There's the cross, but
right here, the cross is gone.
I think that's at 12 deg,
I can't remember,
I think it's 12 degrees out, right?
It's just not there.
It's just plain black.
Okay if I want to do
it with my right eye,
well what I'll do is I'll look at
the cross, and I'll move until I oh!
There it goes.
The circle is gone.
If you are doing this,
if you rotate your head like that,
the cross comes back because the blind
spot is located off to one side and as
I rotate, the blind spot is now up here
and the, and the, the cross pops back.
In class, normally what I do is I
make a bunch of pieces of paper and
I hand this out right here.
Okay, and I ask people to
take their left eye, so, so,
for those of you not paying attention,
so we have a dot, and
over here we have a bar with a cross
hash pattern in the middle of it.
And what I do is,
I tell people to move that dot til
something seems to happen to that bar.
All right, so back here I see the bar
with the cross hash, I move in, and
then something happens, the cross
hash disappears into just a line.